hello everyone welcome to this special
webinar
where we will be discussing projects
related to
infectious diseases research in today's
session
we'll talk about research projects
developed for this program
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
these include research proposals from
the participants in
updated resources on the following
topics
origin and pathogenesis of the novel
coronavirus mutation
frequency in the ebola virus genomes
collected during the 2014
2016 epidemic linking drug resistant
variants in tuberculosis mycobacterium
enterovirus epidemic in children and
contamination of biologics production
this session is part of our
bioinformatics for
infectious diseases online training
program
designed for biologists clinician
students
interested in virology microbiology and
immunology
for this program we have collaborated
with the dokuchi memorial research
institute
for medical research at the university
of khanna
today we are joined by the research
group at noguchi as well as the
participants of the program
in the context of infectious diseases we
will also be discussing some of their
projects
and learn from their experience
let us start by taking a look at the
current progress
of some of the participants who are here
in the program
as indicated by the point system that we
have for all of our omics logic program
we can see how our participants are
doing
and completing this first phase of the
program
successfully we started
phase one which focused on the following
topics
analysis methods and tools for genomic
in transcriptomic data analysis of
host pathogen interaction methods to
study relationships based on
local and global multiple sequence
alignment
phylogenetic analysis and evolutionary
studies
used for genome ancestry and population
fitness
chemical and structural implications of
sequence variation
mapped on pdb models host pathogen
interaction
and treatment response bioinformatics
for infectious diseases
is a six month online training program
where we are learning about the use of
bioinformatics and big data for
infectious disease research
the program ends in the summer after the
first
phase is over we will go on to do
an in-depth training in
transcriptomics and genomic data
the next phase is going to focus on
in-depth training
in genomic data analysis this will start
on march 12 2021. the registration is
now open and anyone with
an interest can sign up i am posting
the link in the chat right now for the
next phase
of this training
so this program also comes with
scholarship opportunities
for students the scholarships we offer
are designed to help motivated talented
and promising students
benefit from special training and
research opportunities
the criteria for approval include a
reasonable need
indication of extra effort that the
participant is willing to put into the
program
and time commitment needed to go beyond
the regular training
this will likely include keeping a
regular record of topics
covered in a detailed lab journal entry
and participant in student facing
presentations
about the learned drop topics
now let me introduce you to the program
mentors
and principal investigators we have dr
harpreet kaur who is a certified omix
logic trainer and expert by information
she guides the hands-on sessions and
assists participants with
projects and analysis during the program
her
area of specialization is in genomics
and machine learning
dr mohit mazumdar is the omics logic
project mentor and an expert in big data
computational analysis
he has a phd in computational biology
and over 10 years of experience working
with
industry and academia we also have
dr anita gansha who is a senior research
fellow
and lecturer at the nagoji memorial
institute at the university of ghana
she is leading the projects as part of
the bioinformatics for
infectious disease program i will now
like to
invite dr mohad mason dar to talk
more about the upcoming program and his
experience with
research projects related to
bioinformatics for
infectious diseases over to you dr
masuda
thank you biph and hello everyone
let me share my screen real quick
okay
so hello everyone yeah so one of the
major focus
of this program bioinformatics for
infectious disease
research and training is to support
ongoing research projects
that are spearheaded by dr anita
gansha's group
at noguchi and her collaborators having
a long history of research
in ghana and other countries in
sub-saharan africa
to track monitor diagnose
and study the spread of drug resistance
malaria
as well as identify noble approaches
to for vaccine design
for as well as interactions between the
malaria host
vectors and pathogens to help conduct
such research
so bioinformatics
offers tools data repositories and
analysis techniques
that we are covering in this training
program
so i've been working for the past
several weeks collecting resources for
malaria omix data so today i wanted to
just
review uh the compilation of the data
resources
and the scientific literature associated
with omics data for malaria research
so to compile uh this article and you
can
see the link below here and beeps if you
can share the link with everyone here as
well
so to compile this article we reviewed
publicly
available data sets generated by
by using next generation sequencing and
uh
we looked into case studies that
demonstrate
the utility of sequencing techniques and
how it
correlates to the drug resistance
in malaria by looking at multi-homics
data
by looking at the entire system biology
aspect
and then diving into the structural
biology
of the by looking at the protein and its
mutations and the structural biology
involved in it
so uh so the objective of this review
is to provide examples and starting
point for students
and researchers who are interested in
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
and especially the genetic diversity
diagnosis
and for the treatment of malaria
so today i wanted to wanted
all of us to take a look at some of the
popular repositories and the
resources listed in the post so the
first
uh image that you can see here is
european
ena or the european nucleotide archive
so
by searching the term plasmodium uh we
can we kind of find out numerous
results for omics data uh on omix data
for this parasite
so this involved uh includes like
here you can see 170 assemblies and
over 400 000 sequences and almost 34
000 uh experiments with 30 000
sequencing
runs so a reference of genomes
annotation of genes
examples of transcriptomic studies so
this is an invaluable resource for
anyone interested in malarial research
using the
our big data so second another
repository is plasmodb
it's very popular uh and is a biological
data
database for genus plasmodium so the
database
is a member of the eu path db project
very very popular project
so this data set and this database
contains extensive
genome proteome and metabolom
information
related to the malarial parasite
so another repository this is here uh
the malaria
host pathogen interaction center i mean
actually it's not uh just a repository
that they host but but uh this mah
pic team they strive to deliver unique
large data sets
i mean that holds potential for major
breakthroughs that ultimately will
advance our understanding for malaria
and help diagnose prevent and treat the
disease so this initiative
or innovation or innovative is a design
of
infectious studies infectious disease
studies
and they're using computational tools to
integrate clinical
uh parasitological functional genomics
proteomics and lipidomics
and also uh metabolomics data
so all of these uh repositories and
their links and
even like the data sets are uh
are listed in that article that has been
just uh shared
so uh then uh thinking about in the
sense of
transcriptomics analysis so
transcriptomics analysis of samples
uh obtained in this human challenge
studies
can also help us deepen our
understanding of the immune response
with that symptom onset allowing that
characterization of innate immunity and
all
also that early gene signatures that
almost always influences the disease
outcome
so gene expression studies uh are
actually helps and facilitates the
identification of
host factors that are contributing in
the disease susceptibility
so one of the places i mean to look for
data that can provide
insights and answers related to gene
expression of the gene
related to the expression of the genes
that can characterize
like this process of infection is the
is the nc ncbi gene expression omnibus
geo so geo is an international public
repositories
repository that archives and is freely
distributed
uh microarray data is there uh ngs data
and other forms of high throughput
functional genomics data
are like regularly submitted by the
research community so these are
information and much more is available
there you can look at
and then as i was telling you that next
we looked into a case study
[Music]
so this case study involving plasmodium
falciparum resistance to chloroquine in
chloroquinine so the uh as
you i think everyone knows that formal
it's a former gold standard for an
anti-malaria drug and now has
a mutant form uh which is causing the
drug resistance uh
basically due to the chloroquine in uh
resistance
transporter gene so pfcrt so
in this here on the
on the left panel you see that there is
a bio project
so a bio project is a compilation which
is available
uh under ncbi so here we found out about
one data set
that has been processed uh with this
mutation
that is uh caused
that caused the you know uh that
caused the mutation at that position and
amino acid so it's leucine
at 275 272 uh position
changing to phil phenin and and the
mutation was identified at
cytosine uh at 814th position changing
to thiamine
so we traced that using the structure
also which is a cryo-em structure
submitted in uh pdb protein databank but
this data set
we found out in ncbi um and they used
i think blastocydin uh
pressure which resulted in this mutation
uh
at the coding region uh so you can find
out all these information
in the blog post and we are expecting
that
out of this resources you'll be able to
find uh some of the key questions that
you have
interest in so one of the objective of
this
program or this uh you know this
webinar is to be able to help
uh those who are starting in this
journey
so we have prepared these articles and
projects and we are looking for research
project ideas and proposals to leverage
these resources and multi-omics data for
noble insights
into the spread of the disease and as i
told you that prevention measures that
can
help address this pressing challenge
across
africa to and to talk about more i mean
it makes more sense and it to talk
about malaria research more i would like
next like to invite
dr anita gansha to talk about
her research and the program so far
thank you for this listening to me and
let me know if you have any questions
related to the resources and the
approaches and the multi-omics
integration approach that we are taking
and then we are looking into the
structural aspect
so i'll be happy to answer your
questions you can reach out to me at
mohit at the ratepine.bio
so i'll be also sharing that in the chat
and now i would like to
hand it over to anita to say a few words
you mohit let me
share my slides
all right so good afternoon to you all
um today i'm not going to really talk
about the studies i have conducted but
um as we began this journey
i think a few weeks ago in january
we've been thinking about projects that
we want to
undertake to finish this
first part of the training
and so at this point some of the
participants are ready to
present um studies that they are
thinking about
this is just um ideas that are still
being
crystallized and so with time you're
going to
develop it further and to
kick start this i have decided to look
at um
investigating similarities and
differences in
host responses to starscope 2 and
plasmodium fossil from infection
and i'm going to do this with dr bright
edu
and we are looking for others to
collaborate
right so a bit about malaria is that
malaria
as mohita said is a parasitic infection
caused by parasites of the genus
plasmodium
and transmitted by the anopheles
mosquitoes
the infection leads to acute and
sometimes life-threatening diseases
and it is a major public health concern
although
it hasn't got done much attention um in
2018 about
228 million cases of malaria
were reported and 405
000 vets and most of these
occurred in sub-saharan africa with
children
under five forming the majority of with
the
morbidity and mortality
we all know the coronavirus disease
covered 19. it's also very infectious
and a global pandemic and everybody is
interested in it and it's caused by
the severe acute respiratory syndrome
growing a virus to
suscope too and when i checked last
night
we had already had 100 million cases
and then 2.4 million plus
deaths globally now
there are some similarities between
malaria and kobet 19.
symptoms or the symptoms of the
disease some of these include the favor
and fever breathing difficulties
tiredness and acute onset of headaches
and this may lead to
misdiagnosis of covid19
for malaria especially in the malaria
endemic
regions and vice versa
this particularly is seen where
a lot of the malaria
diagnosis relies on just the symptoms
and
i can speak for ghana and a lot of
african countries
we self-diagnose and go to pharmacies
and get a treatment based on
these symptoms so it's very likely that
we
have missed a lot of the covet 19.
now as a result
and many many more reasons
we are sure there is a low prevalence of
kobe 19
in malaria endemic countries
and this is what was not originally
expected
considering the fact that these two
infections
may have similar symptoms and you can
imagine
the co-infections with covered in
malaria
may be complex
so some of the reasons that have been
assigned to the low prevalence of kobit
19 in malaria endemic regions
are the age structure there's a lot
about
the fact that covet 19 is most prevalent
in
[Music]
elderly people and the age structure in
africa is more youthful than
in the western world
so people
over 80 or above 65
who seem to have other underlining
conditions
are most affected by covet 19.
but um we've seen that
the age bracket for covert 19 is
lowering
with this second wave of the infection
but there's a whole area that's still
being unraveled
now as i've said there are similarities
between the
copy 19 symptoms and that of malaria
so you can imagine that the immune
responses that
people who have been repeatedly infected
with malaria
may be playing a role
in preventing
very symptomatic or severe covet
infections
in the malaria endemic regions and some
of
these rules have been assigned to the
is two
in malaria and covered basically because
the
and your attention to
[Music]
that is um that is being um
catalyzed by the ace
is found both in covet 19
and also protecting malaria infections
and then the role of interferon and the
neutralizing antibodies
in malaria and covid19 has also been
postulated
to contribute to the low prevalence and
the use of
hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine and
covalent 19. there's a lot of
controversy around that but um
this may also contribute to the low
prevalence
as we keep treating people with
these drugs in sub-saharan africa or
malaria endemic regions
but we also know that the co-infections
with
malaria and covid19 could
the interactions can or would expect it
to
rather western the disease phenotype
so
the problem that i think we have to
unravel
is the fact that even though we have um
significantly lower covet 19
in malaria endemic regions
we you may be expecting war we're
expecting
co-infections to be more harmful
and although the role of the as2
receptor
interferons and neutralizing antibodies
have been postulated to be involved in a
low incidence of
covid19 in africa the full spectrum of
the post similarities and differences
in response to both infections as yet to
be
unraveled so we are proposing to conduct
a
comparative differential gene expression
analysis
on available rna-seq data on the host
cells
infected with plasmodium pulses from and
suscribe 2.
the overall objective is to elucidate
the
significant similarities and differences
in gene expression profiles
and the underlining biological and
molecular mechanisms
specifically we want to conduct a
differential gene expression analysis on
cytoscope 2 and malaria-infected human
cells red blood cells and there are
other cell lines too
and then we're going to control for
transcriptional features
shared by saskof2 and other viral
infections
such as sas mess and h1n1
just to make sure that we are dealing
with covet 19
in our analysis that will determine the
similarity
between the transcriptional features of
source and malaria infect herself
and when we have found these um
differentially expressed genes between
these two
diseases will conduct um gene ontology
analysis to look for the significant
molecular and biological functions
involved in the host responses to
sas group 2 or covet 19 and malaria
we are expecting to obtain the full
scope
spectrum of genes and pathways involved
in both
kobit 19 and malaria
and then to describe the
molecular and biological functions and
aligning the similarities and
differences in the host responses
to covet 19 and malaria
and then we look at the potential
synergy between these host responses to
covet 19 and malaria
so
we have data sets from three studies
one is looking at repeated infections
in children the transcription
or transcriptional profile of children
who have been repeatedly infected with
um
malaria and then the other one
study two has got the
transcriptomes of
individuals and cell lines infected with
suscu mers
h1n1 and then the third study
has got red blood cells infected with
malaria plasmodium fossil from parasites
and the transcriptome analysis of that
and these are the references
thank you very much
thank you anita i also have a question
is anyone else from your group
ready to present because i think i need
to make them co-host to do that
yes i think that um courage and
nigel will also present their way
and ellie
okay
okay i i've made courage the co-host
next so courage if you would like to
share
and about this uh thank you for the
presentation anyway was really
interesting
um i wanted to ask uh there
seems to be a clinical trial that is
just getting started
um are there cases that you know of that
have
both malaria and coven
you mean places mean you would expect
to see that in sub-saharan africa
because yeah are you aware of cases
where people actually got both diseases
at the same time
well i haven't really really looked at
that but i'm sure
bright who has all the data can tell us
that
unless they haven't tested but the
samples are there
and it can be quickly
screened for malaria yeah
okay they might be very common yeah
you think it is common yeah because
about
20 25 of people in
at least ghana are asymptomatically
infected with um
malaria so it's very likely
okay great thank you very much
hello everyone i hope you are doing fine
and everyone see my stream
so my name is uh carriage adobo
and uh i'm proposing approving yet for
these uh courses we are taking
a genetic variation studies of session
stitch specific antigen
pfs 230 and pfs
48 and 45 of plasmodium falciparum
population in ghana
so we know malaria is caused by
malaria caused by plasmodium falciparum
is one of the most
deadly form of malaria especially in
sub-saharan africa affecting millions of
people and
especially children under the age of
five so control
interventions against malaria have seen
the use of anti-malaria drugs like acne
cement
and previously cropping stuffs and then
there are also other vector control
measures but hot
is lacking among these tools is a
broadly effective person
the currently most advanced malaria
vaccine
rtss has shown
low efficacy in clinical malaria
this low efficacy studies have shown
that is largely due to the genetic
diversity of the targeted
antigen which is the second sporazoid
protein
now transmission blocking vases
will induce responses against
the malaria para sites gametocytes
sexual stages thereby blocking
fertilization and
reproduction two antigens
pfs 230 and pfs 48 and 45
which are expressed on the surface of
gametocyte have been shown
in uh research papers that
the lacy's strong immune responses
however
genetic diversity of these antigens have
not been fully explored
in the ghanaian parasite population
so the problem is the efficacy of
current
malaria vaccines are hindered due to the
diverse nature of
the antigens
and to have a successful transmission
blocking vaccine
it will have to induce the immune
responses against the malaria parasites
at the gametophyte stage however the
genetic diversity of
transmission blocking vasons vascinating
have not been fully exploding
the ghanian population
so there is the need to therefore
explore the genetic diversity of this
transmission blocking antigen to further
estimate how effective vasons will be
if they target those antigens
so the objective
of the project is to scan for
uh genomic regions inside these antigens
and then find variations in them in the
population
and then identify the types of mutations
that these variations
cause and further see whether these
mutations
the functional effects they have on the
translated proteins
so i'll take my data set from uh
malaria gene the public
like the community project and this is
the url to the various data sets
references thank you
uh and uh courage you just had a
question uh were you going to work on
this on your own or is there anyone else
that you're planning to work together
with
i've not found i've not gotten any
partner yet
so uh for now i'm working
on it alone but i'm looking for partners
okay so you're open for others to join
you if they're injured right
yes okay
and uh so um i guess at the end of this
session we can talk more about
what it would be an effective way to
partner on these different project
proposals thank you
if anyone has any questions or comments
on this please
feel free to add those
and uh if for anyone else that's going
to be presenting if you could just start
off with just a few words about yourself
uh your background kind of you know how
you ended up getting interested in this
project
i think that would also help others uh
consider how they may contribute
so you know if your background is in
bioinformatics or your background is in
uh something else i think it would be
more easy for people to see what they
can contribute
thank you courage so i assumed the next
person would be
benedicta
can someone else present our
presentation
i'm not ready okay who who else is ready
to present um nigel i think
yeah and i'm ready to present so let me
share my screen
okay i think i need to make you a
co-host one second
okay nigel i made you a co-host
all right thank you very much
hello everyone and my name is nigel
dolan
i'm a research assistant at the gucci
memorial school for medical research
and my background is in bioinformatics
i'm working under dopamine
with my supervisor by api and
my background in mathematics entails
computational drug discovery
and nuclear policies like
ulsa and tuberculosis
leprosy and then also
malaria and so this projects that i'm
thinking about
is regards to malaria and it's
a competition guided approach towards
the discovery of natural product
compounds resistance to
pfmrd1 and pfcrt
that two gene mutations which have been
known to compare
potassium atomicity resistance and
plasminoposal
so the background malaria which is a
protozoan
infection is caused by plasmodium
parasites and this remains
a major cause of mobility and mortality
worldwide primarily
primarily among children less than five
years old
and yes in 2018 it was estimated to have
caused
around 220 million cases globally of
which next three percent
which is which constitutes 113 million
okay in africa according to population
now the mafic on t p phosphor malaria
parasite prevalence in africa and the
presence of children
infected with p phosphorus so in if in
blue
and blue yet blue blue shows the low
areas
where we might see one or two infested
children out of hundreds
whilst in all in high areas which are
which indicates by red
it might be more than 50. now this alone
demonstrates how
and change the disease remains
throughout much of western central
africa and parts of the artifaction
however this is not a gloom as there
have been therapeutic gains
in trying to kept this minutes the
recent and current frontline therapy is
that synonym
based combination therapies or the acts
and these have been invaluable
in the substantial decline of the burden
of malaria
the challenge yes again yet again
however
the two main pillars for malaya control
and
beyond remain targeting the unofficial
vector
and effective case management which is
crucially dependent on the efficacy
of the deployed and smaller drugs caring
and activities
and yet there's a growing concern that
that serves it starts to question the
effects of the therapy
there have been reports of treatment
failure of activities in southeast asia
and this parasite is just relentless
i must see anti-malarial drug resistance
in plasminophosphate tends to image
in low transmission settings
in particular in southeast asia or south
america before expanding to high
transmission
settings in sub-saharan africa
arrival in sub-saharan africa of these
very
difficult to treat parasite strains can
have a huge impact on malaria mobility
anxiety
and yes they have arrived
because mutations in 2014
reports established that resistance
attempting is due to
the count propeller domain of the
process however
importance of the study are the pf
crt and then pf mdr1
so allows of plasmodium phosphorus
chlorine
resistant transporter gene which is the
pfcrt
have been associated with chlorine
resistance and plasminophosphorum
and then the plus model multi first
modem for super multi drug resistance
that's the pf
mdr 1 gene it's associated with both
chlorine
and ammo diacon resistance
so you you'll see in this image here
that the parasite which is shown in gray
a grey oval is shown within the red
blood cell which is in red
the dv which is the digestive vacuole of
the parasite
it's a comparison within a process where
the catabolism of immunoglobulin
from the host are blood vessel case
the breakdown of hemoglobin results in
reactivity which is toxic to the
parasites
and undergoes detoxification to to
become
chromosomes now medications from
chloroquine class bind him and interfere
with detoxification
but pfcrt
and pfmdr1 which which are dv
or digestive vacuum membranes
proteins this thoughts that the pfcrt
transports drug out of the the dv
while the pf mdr-1 transports tracks
into the db now the mutation in the pr
pfcrt is essential to chlorine
resistance
while that's in the pfmdr-1 it's
essential to
to augment also chlorine resistance
and mutation in these transporters have
been found to mediate the resistance of
a tetamine
at a missingness and that's the goal
this will therefore seek to virtually
screen multiple natural compound
libraries from
different databases first of all to
identify compounds which could
potentially have final affinities
against both the wild and mutants
pfmdr-1
and pfcrt now to what end is this the
end of which is to identify compounds
which could potentially circumvent the
resistance of regions
pf mdr-1 and pfcrt so that at the end of
the day we would have
new compounds that would essentially be
moved to become drugs
that would address the issue of
resistance
regards to this process and the minutes
you should produce malaria and so these
are my data sets
and my references thank you very much
okay great thank you everyone or uh
sorry thank you nigel
uh would you be also open to others
contributing to your project
yes please i'll be okay so i'll just
mention it
all right next one thank you very much
um
so again the process for anyone to
contribute to these projects
either from the participants of the
current program you know
everyone involved uh for those who are
not a part of the pro
program of this program we're going to
discuss the upcoming program on genomic
data
analysis as well as the research
fellowship if you're a part of the
research fellowship we can also probably
match with somebody who you're
interested to contribute to and it will
be up to them to decide
if they're open to that contribution who
would be
are there any questions sorry for nigel
okay if there's not who would be the
next person presenting
hello i have a question yes
yes my name is ayo fayong so my question
thank you nigel for the wonderful
presentation so i was just thinking
your project is time to look for
compounds that will
inhibit those two genes both the white
and the
mutant genes now
how are you going to get data that will
show that will
have an array of compounds to test
since we are looking for compounds and
or is that that data that
has all of the possible compounds which
you can actually test for
thank you thank you very much are you in
dm
i was something i forgot to add to m so
this study is also compressed because at
the end of the um
i would be looking at the band affinity
of those compounds
regards to an atomism and so how
well they do determines um whether or
not we are going for with those
particular components
and then so um zyng database was
mentioned
further data said sting database has a
catalogue of
compounds which in the subset of which
are some of them are from africa so you
would have afrodb which has a catalogue
of
a number of compounds and so
my my research is targeted towards
compounds that are from africa
that are going to screen against these
genes
then see the ones that perform better
than um
listening and go forward with it yes so
this is just a clearing statement yeah
thank you
all right great um thank you um
benedicta would you like to go next
yes please hello hello i also have a
question for nigel
okay um in just for the sake of time
if we could move on to benedicta but we
you can post your questions in the chat
and we'll make sure to uh
you know share the contact details for
you know more questions after that okay
all right thanks thanks a lot okay thank
you another time
go ahead benedict
okay benedict are you able we cannot
hear you or see your screen
okay benedicta can you still hear us
okay maybe it seems like uh
he lost the connection i feel yeah
was the connection okay so um
maybe we can continue and she will join
back
uh we also wanted to explain
a little bit more about how
these projects are formed
and how anyone can get started with a
project even without having a lot of
information on bioinformatics
and other things as you've been addicted
joined back
benedict can you hear us
okay so um
i don't know i can take it from here and
introduce everyone
to the research pollution
okay great thank you pepsi thank you
so as uh many of you are interested in
collaboration or looking for
opportunities of how to work on
projects like this we have this research
fellowship
program so
i want to thank uh dr gansha
courage and nigel for presenting we are
looking forward to seeing their projects
fully fleshed out
for the remainder of the bioinformatics
for infectious disease program
participants
of the training and our other research
fellows will be collaborating together
with our mentors
and experts from the topper
bioinformatics research center on
completing the analysis
and to give everybody a sense of how the
research component of the program works
i'm going to be sharing a few more
slides about the research fellowship
program that we have
so one of the main challenges uh that we
have seen
from many researchers students as well
as research fellows who are starting
their bioinformatics work is to prepare
a research plan that fits with the type
of data
and leverages big data analysis tools
effectively
so we have a step-by-step process
which guides our research fellows and
helps them understand the logic first
and then apply it to their own research
question
so as a result anyone starting on this
journey in bioinformatics can start
developing a project
of their own in fact we have already
worked with many students who have
completed the training
and developed interesting research
projects
which have won awards and even got
published in peer
journals so here are some of those
projects
by our graduated research fellows
who have worked on these different areas
of bioinformatics research
yes and for all of you who are showing
your interest
in the chat box please put your email id
down
or please email us at marketing at
pine.bio or
africa pipe dot bio so we also have a
team in africa who
support us who support the biotech team
so
you could also reach out to them and
thank you fiza for
sharing so as i mentioned many of the
past participants
had the chance to present their analysis
in front of their classmates or at a
conference
in poster sessions or workshops so here
is an example
from one of such conference that we had
in baton rouge in louisiana
so where we presented on different
topics
and here was a presentation by our team
so to help participants reach this stage
of a complete project that they can then
present
to a larger audience we work with them
through the steps of the project design
so we have these different steps that we
have in the project
design process that we work with
each one of the participants so each
research fellows goes through this
process
starting with learning about the
different multi-omics
topics then completing certain tasks
related to them
then starting their literature review on
an area that they are interested
in researching on working to find
data sets which would be apt for the
kind of
problem that they are trying to solve
and finally
going forward with their analysis their
presentation
presenting to an audience like we have
today with a wider
audience of people getting it reviewed
by our
experts at the topper bioinformatics
research center and then finally
taking it to a stage where it can become
a publication like you see here
so this is a very step-by-step process
and the research fellowship is offered
for a period of either
three months minimum or a period of six
months
it can go in longer but what we aim to
do is that we start this process by
training
each research fellow making them
familiar with the topic making them
familiar
with the research that is going on in
the different domains
so it can be anything it's not just
infectious diseases
you can be interested in oncology you
can be
interested in precision medicine like to
see this project here
so there are a lot of opportunities for
everybody
interested in different topics we also
have a working group right now who are
working on
alzheimer's so there are these different
opportunities available for everyone
that you can explore as part of the
research
fellowship process and
for example this is a project that was
developed by dr gansha
in collaboration with dr emika patrick
chubbucka
in part of the research fellowship
program where they were looking at the
analysis of transcriptome profile of
sars cop2 infected cell lines
to understand the mechanism of action of
repurposed drugs for cobit 19 treatment
so as you see dr gansha has already
spoken about
how uh we are looking at the different
uh prevalence of kobit 19
and malaria across regions in africa
so this was one of the projects she
worked on related to over 90.
so now to help those who are starting in
this journey
our team has prepared several advanced
research projects that anyone can
take to learn more about genomic and
transcriptomic data
in application to various pathogens i
would like to invite dr
core to present some of the new projects
that are available right now
on our platform dr core over to you
thank you bhipsa
so hello everyone my name is harpreet
kaur and i have a phd in bioinformatics
in my current role i am omix logic
bioinformatics trainer with the pine
biotech
so here i am assisting participants to
learn about data analysis
machine learning and visualization in
the application to the large
datasets used in the biomedical research
so besides i am involved in designing
different research projects using
publicly available data with our team
members at
find biotech here we are continuously
designing different research projects
using publicly available data
based on the studies published in high
impact
journals thus we have collection of
project where you can learn
how bioinformatics can be applied in the
field of
infectious disease using publicly
available ngs data
so the first project here
is on ebola so as we know ebola virus
cause a deadly
ebola virus disease in the human which
is also sometimes referred as
ebola hemorrhagic fever so for out of
the six
known ebola virus cause life-threatening
viral infection in the
humans which is also highly contagious
so the recent epidemic outbreak in west
africa has raised concern about the
implication of this virus
on a human population so here we have
designed a dedicated project on ebola
based on the original publication data
to understand
its reason and to find out what are
important mutation or the variance
that are for this particular malignancy
sorry for this particular outbreak
so during the 2014-2016 outbreak of the
ebola in the west africa happened across
different regions
the next generation sequencing can be
used on the last scalar to
large scale to track the development of
this epidemic
so here we used genome sequence data
from the ebola virus stream to perform
msc and the phylogenetic analysis
so we used multiple sequence alignment
and phylogenetic analysis
to determine the evolutionary
relationship between these genome
so we have identified a group of samples
and how they are related to its
phenotype
so the phenotype that we choose here in
this case is its
geological location that is the country
from where it is originated
like gabon liberia or uk
next we also see how we can analyze
multiple sequence alignment and
nucleotide label
and amino acid label to understand the
differences
and the mutation among different samples
so we will learn what are the key
mutation in a specific
reasons that result alteration in the
pathogenicity
so we also analyze mutation between
groups of the sample using comparative
analysis to study mutability
so this smell method helped us to
identify the origin of polymorphism
which is believed to a cause
of an increase in the ability of virus
to enter the
host cell
and the next project is on covid19
so when this kovid19 pandemic outbreak
happen so there are the several question
questions arise that needs to be
addressed
so these questions can be like from
where it is originated
or from which animal or from which
location it is originated
so how it start infecting humans
so for this purpose to understand this
we have designed
a project on covid19 that is reason in
the pathogenesis of noble coronavirus
so here first based on the multiple
sequence alignment and the phallogenetic
analysis
we will try to understand its genetic
unitic reason that is
from where from which animal it is it
has been originated
so in this you will learn to perform
phylogenetic analysis to understand
the reason whether how it is associated
with the other strains of coping 19 as
well
so then multiple sequence alignment will
help us to understand
what are the measle differences and the
variations taking place
between the different strains of the
covin-19
so in the next part we will also learn
how and we can obtain uh what are the
different key components
or the protein components in the virus
and the host that are responsible for
its
patho density for instance is to
receptor
winds to spike protein so how you can
visualize the structure of this protein
and its complex with the east to spy
ace to so how you can
understand the differences between the
different reasons in the structure
so we have incorporated this part as
well
in the next part we also we will also
have try to incorporate transcriptomics
data analysis to identify
a signature that can discriminate
the sample that are rexella native
treated
and untreated samples
so here we have employed different data
exploratory analysis approaches like
uh differential gene expression analysis
principle component analysis and hair
clustering to understand
what are important signature that can
distinguish these classes of the samples
then the third project is about
tuberculosis
so here we have designed this project to
understand the
drug resistant variant in the
mycobacterium
as we know one third of the world
population has been infected with
tuberculosis so this tuberculosis is
caused by
mycobacterium tuberculosis so this
disease has
severe symptoms including chronic blood
present in the sputum
than the weight loss etc but the major
concern with the
tuberculosis is the drug resistance in
the mycobacterium
so there was a research work was
published
in one of the top journal that is in
lancet so where the
authors have performed whole genome
sequencing for the prediction of the
mycobacterium tuberculosis drug
susceptibility and resistance
in this study authors sequenced a
training set of nearly
2100 mycobacterium tuberculosis genome
so we have taken this data so
in this project we have employed various
jivas approach to
identify those genes that are associated
with the
drug resistance here mainly we use
gamma plink and the slope methods
then the next project is about
enterovirus
d68 out to be so one of the diseases
that is
acute flaccid myelitis which is a severe
neurogenic disease in the children
caused by this evd 68
virus so this afm disease is like a
polio life
defined by the acute onset of flaccid
paralysis in the setting of
spinal mra demonstrating a longitudinal
lesion in the gray matter of the code
so in this project we have tried to
understand the evolutionary relationship
between the strains
from various outbreaks of evd 68 and
which are occurring at different time
points
based on the ngs data
so uh it is first immersed around 1968.
but in the last decade this outbreak of
evd60 has been
evd 68 has been reported across the
different parts of the globe
particularly in the us and the europe
like after
every couple of years like 20 uh it
first it uh recently it was happened
like 20 of
uh 2012 and 2014 2016 and so on
so there they have also observed the
pathogenicity
of this particular virus is actually
varying among different
output outbreaks so
here we have used multiple sequence
alignment as well as
various phylogenetic analysis using
different
phylogeny reconstruction algorithms to
find out whether
ebd strains from the different outbreaks
at different points
are the same or the different based on
the phallogenetic and
multiple sequence analysis
and further we have identified the diff
how they are different based on the
phylogenetic analysis
then the multiple sequence alignments
indicate there are
number of the variations occurring in
this in these strains
but not all the mutation transfer to
transfer at the amino acid level still
there are like two to three percent of
the variations they
taking place so
participants can explore all these
projects and
learn about how you can employ various
bioinformatics approaches to analyze
ngs data from various infectious
pathogens
so that's all so now i would like pass
this session back to the pipsa
so over to you thank you so much uh dr
harpreet
so i want to take this opportunity to
invite you all to
see where the projects that dr harper
just introduced
is on the platform so if you are again
joining us for the first time
please come with me to edu tb info i
will be posting this
in the chat box right now so once you
are in this platform
you will notice so i'm already logged in
so you'll
find if you're not logged in either a
register or a login button
and you can register with either an
email id or there are
also registration via any of your social
media ids
so please go ahead and register
and if you're already on the platform
please put down number one
in the chat box so that i know that at
least some of you are there in the
platform and you can
explore the resource that i'm showing
along with me
so please put number one in the chat box
thank you emmanuel
anybody else who is on the edu platform
thank you martha and courage and
elizabeth
anybody else thank you nigel
so we already have a lot of you are in
the platform
and also part of this training program
okay thank you saida
so let us explore the first free
resource now i know that
many of you who are present in today's
meeting have already taken this course
but for anybody who is joining us for
the first time we recommend
you to take the introduction to
bioinformatics and the reason
is this course introduces you to the
different opportunities available
and we encourage everyone to take the
course so that
you can go ahead and take a take the
intro survey
which gives us an idea about who you are
and what your interest is so this helps
us to
collaborate with you on your area of
interest and provide you
those opportunities which are available
in the area you're interested in
so the next step is to find the project
so if you
note in the projects if you click on
this column it will open up to this tab
so these are the projects that dr hudson
has been showing you
so let us
see the projects which are there so we
discussed tuberculosis
covert 19 the ebola project
and here are the direct links so some of
these
projects like the kovit 19 project
is free and available for everyone
to start taking the project
so i'm posting the direct links but you
can again go from the project section
right here
and you can see more or you can just
click here it will lead you
to this project page and as i mentioned
that
these projects are not just on
infectious diseases
there are more projects on different
areas you have
projects also on cancer and oncology
which are here so please feel free to
explore these projects and if you want
to study what
other participants have done in the
previous program
i'm going to be sharing with you a link
to the
project examples so here is the link to
project examples from
our previous participants who have taken
part in such training programs
and have successfully done a project
so most of these participants who have
been featured in this project
example page are our research fellows
so they have done some of their work and
it is featured here
many of them are going towards working
on
a publication or working on writing a
paper
so these are the different projects that
you can see
and they cover different areas and
applications of
bioinformatics to different kinds of
data sets
so please feel free to explore this page
as well and as for the next steps like
what are the different
options that i have that you have to
join
a program like this so as i mentioned
earlier so you have already the
upcoming genomics program as part
of the next step or the phase two of the
bioinformatics for infectious disease
program
and this is open for registration if you
are
interested we have already also
mentioned the research
fellowship the next program
which is available is the omex logic
transcriptomics program
so this is a program completely on rnac
data analysis so if you are interested
in learning more about
ngs data then this is a program for you
the other program which is ongoing so
this program has already started on
february 16th but you can still enroll
for the program
if metagenomics is an area that you are
interested
in learning and this program is also a
collaborative program
with an institute in nigeria called the
helix biogen institute
so this program had had only two
sessions so far
it's open for registration so you can
also join this program so we are
covering different omics topics is
part of these programs and
another program which is starting very
soon from march 15
is a program on precision oncology
so we are going to be studying example
data sets
and talk a lot about cancer and the role
of precision medicine
in understanding a disease like cancer
and here are the different
links to enroll in these different
programs so let
me quickly share with you the links so i
believe that there is a lot of links
if you are interested in something
particular please
let us know i'm going to be sharing all
the
pages where you can actually enroll for
each of these
programs so please feel free to
log in to these pages and enroll for the
program
so i think uh thank you beeps i just
wanted to mention
uh to all of those that are already uh
participating in the infectious disease
program
uh you have until the end of today to
finalize your submissions
of your project proposals because we
will need at least
three days to review all of the project
proposals
with our collaborators at the tower
bioinformatics research center
and with dr ganza so that we can
finalize it by our next session on
friday
and uh if you have any questions about
your project proposal
if you are finding it difficult to find
a data set
or you don't really know if there is
something that you would like to
focus on consider joining one of the
proposed projects that we saw today
from nigel from dr gansa from
courage uh i don't know if benedicta
is still uh wanting to present her
project
uh but those would be
projects to consider to contribute to
and then also
one of these projects described by dr
kaur
who showed these are projects that you
can start with
but then you can expand on those by
adding additional data sets
or trying some of the other example
uh methods that you've learned about in
the
program that we are doing right now
so benedict would you still like to
share
um yes if you can hear me now yeah we
can hear you
great
can you see my screen yes we can
but you probably should change the
screen because we see your presenter
view
okay
you can change it right above where it
says display settings you can just do
yeah see it says swap
yeah okay
so the cycle of my project is looking at
the structure
patterns of diversity and selection of
plasmodium falciparum ethical membrane
fruits and
one gene in ghana and also across
multiple populations in the world so my
name is benedictsa
so um i have a background in
biochemistry
epidemiology and biostats and then
somewhat
knowledge and based status in
bioinformatics sorry i still have
biostatistics here
and my research interest is in
molecular and genetic epidemiology
more specifically looking into
infectious diseases
and non-communicable diseases such as
um cancer so this project is
an extension of my phd work where we did
sequence the
become membrane protein and a little
background
into that is the ethical membrane
protein is
a transmembrane protein that is um
released um into the surface of the
nerves like
protein during inflation of neurozoids
into
erythrocytes that's the rpcs and some
studies have shown
um it it's been under selection by the
immune system
and it's one of the primary targets for
malaria person
development and to effectively
prevent malaria and subsequently
eradicate as they need for us to develop
an infective malaria person
so the end of this project is to look at
um the genetic diversity
of the ama1 gen and whether this is
under um balancing selection or immune
selection
and also to look at the structure of the
pfd in new engine and to see whether
the variations that we see in ghana and
also variations that we see in other
parts of the world like
um south east asia and south um
eastern africa to see whether this
affects the
protein structure and also functions
such as um
immune selection
so um the product summary involves
looking at
um diversity indices such as nucleotide
sequence diversity
haplocyte diversity the amino acid
sequence diversity and also look at the
um the protein structure in this folding
look at fsd and genetic structure for
instance looking at
pcas to see whether these genotypes
um clustered differently for the
different populations such as
west africa and then also some other
parts like
southeast asia and also to determine the
evidence of selection using
[Music]
and also um from this course i've
learned
how to do the 3d profiling of protein
structure
so that's what this main project i would
be focusing on to see
whether differences in these nucleotides
affects the protein structure
and whether this also affects how
these different genotypes which are
functionally selected by the immune
system
so i will use data that we have
generated here at moguchi
ngs data and also data
from a project that's the male region
where they sequence
the whole falciparum genome for
multiple countries so i would extract
data of the i'll extract the ama1
gene data from those projects and then
compare to see
the indices that i have indicated to see
well how they
um differ between the ghanaian
populations and then
also other populations across the world
thank you
uh thank you and so can you just
describe a little bit better
specifically what type of data you
mentioned you have your own data but
there's also this publicly available
data
um so what exactly do what type of data
is this
just that one gene so it's amplifying
for that gene
no it's it's the whole genome of
falsehood
so i'm gonna extract the ama1 gene and
then compare
and what kind of metadata is available
for that data
um is it just resistant
non-resistant or is it also resistant to
different types of drugs or anything
else like this
so as as resistance this is
a malaria project so it's just it
sequence the whole genome
and then you can um decide so i have the
link to the product but i
am interested in looking at the ama1 gym
so
i'm not sure what kind of metadata they
have
there but i'm sure
there's a sequences of the whole genome
so
okay and are you uh interested
in others potentially contributing to
your project
yes please even one is interested
all right great thank you very much
anita did you want to
add anything to that yeah i was going to
say that the
malaria gen project does not really
have available meta
data just the location of the
um samples and sometimes
the level of prosthenia but if one is
interested then you have to
apply and then you know the
resistance status or information
about the clinical study
that went with the data what are you
people doing
nobody is speaking okay
thank you for that clarification anita
so if anyone has any questions about
this project
or how to join i hope that we were able
to answer all of those questions
and again just to kind of summarize
this webinar this webinar is a part of
our ongoing program
this program is designed for research
kind of transitioning into research
by those who have received the training
that we have
and we also have a number of
other programs and resources that pipsa
mentioned so
beeps i'll pass it on back to you to
wrap it up
thank you so much uh dr manson thank you
elia
and also dr ganza so as we are ending
today's session i want to ask if you
have any questions and
as you see on my screen right now i'm
sharing our linkedin page
so this is also a group where we
collaborate with a lot
of participants from all over the world
so please
feel free to go ahead and join the group
i've posted the link
in the chat box and we also have a
similar
facebook group here as well so any of
these social media channels that
you feel comfortable in please go ahead
and follow us
and you will also find snippets of
uh of what we do shared in our instagram
page at buying for matrix spine
so you're able to find us on all of
these social media channels
so please continue to follow us in any
of these places
and we hope that you not only follow us
but also
gain something out of this we share
interesting research
articles from time to time we talk a lot
about our programs
we talk a lot about the job
opportunities which are there especially
on our linkedin and our facebook groups
so please feel free to take advantage of
this
opportunity and see if you are also able
to
share with our other members something
that you feel interested in and you can
have a conversation
so what we intend with our community
here at pine biotech is that our
bioinformatics community
can not only learn from a program like
this
or collaborate on projects but they
continue to learn
from each other and collaborate with
everybody who is present in that group
so fizza has a question are all the
projects discussed here
a part of the bioinformatics research
program i mean do i need to register for
every course individually
or overall registration is required so
all the projects that are mentioned
here would be available as part of the
research fellowship
program so
what you need to do is that when we
start the research fellowship program
with you you would need to specify
a particular area now there are a lot of
projects
that i have shown you say for example
uh there was this ebola project so if
you're particularly interested in one
project we would be working to make sure
that you are learning all about ebola
now you can definitely do other projects
but
what we try to do as part of the
research fellowship or any of our
training programs
is to make sure that you're focused on
one particular direction because
firstly as i uh mentioned while i was
presenting that
it's not easy always to come up with a
particular
form of analysis find the right data set
so those are some of the struggles that
we see
every research fellow um
notwithstanding what their educational
qualification is or how much they know
they struggle with because these are not
easy to come up so you are going to
spend
a lot of time on one particular topic so
yes
you can choose any of this research
projects in fact
the projects that we mentioned as part
of the examples
all of those projects are novel research
projects which means that we have not
proposed those topics so the projects
that you see here
have been proposed by these students or
these participants who have taken part
in the research fellowship program so
they propose the projects
and they can only propose the projects
once they go through this
entire process of training learning
going through the different example
projects
and then understanding that okay so once
i've learned from here what are the
different
opportunities to uh explore this in a
different
research question so that is exactly
what the research fellowship is about
so you can choose any of these topics
now coming to
iorinda's question can one still join
this program despite having started
since
january and would end in a few days so
iron day as we mentioned that this is a
six month long program
which we are doing with noguchi now the
first part of the program bioinformatics
for infectious diseases
is going to be over you cannot join that
program now
the next program that we have and you
can join is the omics logic genomics
program
so this is phase two of the program
where we are going to be talking about
genomic data analysis
in respect to bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
so it's a continuation of the training
program and the next again
the training that we are going to be
talking about is transcriptomics
so you can still join this program which
is going to be starting
on march 12th it is completely open for
registration
so you have not been a part of the first
part of the training but
as if you see this program and its
syllabus
it starts with a very introductory
session
so we have broken down this entire six
month program
into different parts and you can still
take part in this program as we are
going to be starting right from
like you can say stage one and building
up your
understanding of genomic data and how to
work with that kind of data
so here you can find the different
uh syllabus for the program so you can
see the different dates which are there
the different topics that will be
covered on each of these dates
so you can definitely join this program
again
so do we have any other questions
that you want us to address right now
because we are almost
close to ending today's session
and again if you still have some
questions uh
and if you do not have them right now
please feel free to reach out to us at
marketing at pine
dot bio so okay so for emmanuel's
question
which is about metagenomics so
metagenomics started i mentioned
on february 16th so we have had only
very two
introductory session and our next
session
is not until tomorrow so tomorrow is
going to be like the third
session so we have just started so if
anyone is interested we welcome you to
go ahead
and join the metagenomics program as
well
so this is like i feel it's a wrong link
so if you have put in your email address
i think you manually have already shared
with us the email address
we will be sharing with you the details
and as i mentioned we also have
a team in africa so let me share with
you the correct
address i think adidas has also shared
it in the chat box
so you can also reach out to the africa
team
at africa pine dot bio
so if you go to the
okay let me share the email id again in
the chat box
right so what i wanted to show you is
that we have had only
this introductory session and this
session on
microbiome as a functional bacterial
community
and the next session is going to be
tomorrow
so if you're interested please go ahead
and join and if you need more
information you can reach out to either
of these email ids
so you can reach out either to me or
to adidas africa pine dot bio
and thank you aditya for uh sharing this
so i hope that uh this is all clear to
you
we are having several different programs
uh that suit different research
interests
so you can reach out to us and i hope
that
with all of the different programs
available you are not overwhelmed
because if you are
you are again can ask us questions and i
think we will be able to help you
address
some of those questions so we had a
question regarding like data science
program
so we had just concluded a data science
program as
uh like in january so that program
started and has already
ended now if anyone is interested in
doing a data science program
you would have to go through the
research fellowship process which means
that if you're part of the research
fellowship program
we are going to be doing the same kind
of training we did as part of the data
science program
and you will be going through those
similar resources on machine learning
and data science
and you can take the program again
because we do not have any upcoming data
science program which is
dedicated to it like we have for media
genomics or transcriptomics
i hope that clears everybody's doubts
and regarding all of the details so once
you fill up the form
we will be sending you email regarding
all the details on how to join the
program
and as i mentioned earlier for each of
the programs we
do offer scholarships so the
scholarships are
offered to students who
like who present that they are able to
take up the additional responsibility of
attending each of the sessions
sharing with us updates of their
progress
so if the student has to be very
dedicated so once you submit one of
these scholarship
applications what we do is we invite you
and one of your reference
to a one-on-one meeting where we meet
with you
explain to you how the program works and
what you
would be required of you so if you are
able to agree you are offered that
scholarship
and this can either be a full
scholarship or a partial scholarship so
this completely
depends on like how you're coming
and like presenting yourself so that
would be completely dependent
and then we would be sending you an
email regarding this
so if you're applying for the
scholarship position or you need
help with the scholarship you can again
email us and we'll be sending you the
details
so whenever you are emailing us please
mention the name of the programs as we
have mentioned quite a number of
programs here
and we would like love to help you with
the program that you are seeking so
please mention the name of the program
you are wanting to
apply for and we'll be helping you with
all the details it is either
myself or aditya
we will be the session is recorded uh
a fun so we will be sending you the
video of
the session
if there are any questions
yeah thank you aditya
so i welcome you all to join either of
the training programs and collaborate
with each other yes the fellowship
program
also has a fee so
if you go to this link you will be able
to see all the details
of the fellowship program i'm again
sharing this
in the email or if you fill out the form
you will also receive an email which
will have all the details